one problem for investigators today
security cameras that could have caught
the incident on video were not working a
cbs news review shows that there were
years of warnings about the
vulnerability of security cameras in the
new york city subway scott mcfarland has
more on these warnings and the potential
risk for other transit systems across
america scott good morning to you gail
good morning to you bus stations and
subways across america are blanketed by
security cameras but the new york
transit agency was warned multiple times
over the past five years simply having
the cameras
isn't enough
when they were needed most the cameras
failed there were three stations that
the video wasn't working but it wasn't
without warning in a pair of inspections
from 2018 and 2019 reviewed by cbs news
state officials warned new york city's
metropolitan transportation authority
that transit station security cameras
were at risk of malfunctions finding the
transit agency failed to ensure
preventative maintenance and timely
repairs on thousands of the cameras the
transit system responded it was taking
aggressive steps does it surprise you to
hear that this camera in this spot may
not have been working right it does not
surprise me to hear it's very easy after
an event that that's horrifying and
scary to the public for policy makers to
to reach for that silver bullet solution
we'll put cameras in all all the subway
stations uh but that initial expense
doesn't necessarily provide uh or
explain all of the resources that will
have to go into that kind of
surveillance former fbi agent mike
german says cameras are a challenge for
many u.s transit systems because they
require regular and sophisticated
maintenance congressional sources tell
cbs news a group of dozens of u.s house
members were already getting ready to
request millions of dollars later this
month to pay for cameras and other types
of security equipment harder
infrastructure
and surveillance training to help
prevent attacks at u.s rail stations
democrat abigail spanberger formerly
with the cia says equipment alone won't
stop a threat maintenance is important
if there's cameras where is that
video uploaded where is it stored who is
reviewing it when we're looking at
security investments
they do require maintenance and they do
require continued investment
last year new york's transit agency
announced it had cleared a milestone
installing cameras in all 470 plus
subway stations but now police say
they're investigating whether these
cameras on this day suffered a
mechanical or electrical malfunction
gail okay need some work to be done
there thank you very much scott